Yeah,
it might be the worst date on your weekly calendar,
but it's a date.
You definitely don't want to stand up garbage day.
You Tie it all up into neat plastic bags,
hollered outside and like magic.
Your home smells fresh again and that makes you happy.
Yeah,
we believe in the magical world of trash,
out of sight,
out of mind,
but really we just hide it on in places like this.
Did you know the world produces 1.2 billion tons of waste every year by the year
2100 will be producing 3.6 billion tons of waste.
How much longer can we rely on landfills?
What if we need more space?
How much would it cost?
What kind of infrastructure would we need and what could go wrong?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we sent our junk to space.
We've got a lot of junk on this planet and it's only getting worse.
So shooting our trash into space sounds like an easy,
obvious solution.
After all,
we've been going into space since the 1950s surely now it's easier than ever.
Yeah,
it's possible.
We can shoot our garbage into space,
but it certainly wouldn't be easy.
The operation would be astronomically expensive,
requiring millions of rocket launches every year,
which would not only be damaging to the global environment,
but could also hinder future space travel.
And all this is assuming that things go according to plan.
Since the start of the space age,
5,038 rockets have been launched into space.
We've sent probes as far as Neptune,
and in 2018 NASA sent a probe on a course to the outer atmosphere of the sun.
So in theory,
the solar system is that our disposal for our disposal.
But how would it work on Ariane?
Five rocket carries a payload of up to 7,000 kilograms to a stable point in
Earth's orbit.
It can do this at a cost of around $200 million,
but since the world produces one point 2 trillion kilograms of trash per year,
we need to launch about 168 million Arriann fives every year to keep the globe
garbage free.
And all this would cost,
oh,
only about 33 quadrillion dollars per year.
We don't have to tighten our belts.
If we want to make this work.
Since worldwide GDP,
it's $77 trillion.
We're a bit short,
but we're not just short on cash.
We're short on resources.
91 orbital rockets were launched in 2017 which might sound like a lot,
but it's nothing compared to the 168 million launches.
We'd have to accommodate the bottom line.
If we want to send our garbage into the cosmos,
we'll need to start building a lot more spaceports,
a lot more launchpads and we've got to do it fast,
but suppose we somehow found a way to supply the infrastructure and foot the
bill.
There are some things we can't control.
Russia's Soyuz space launch system is the most successful of all time.
It's success rate is a stunning 97% for every 1000 lunches.
Now apply that percentage to 170 million launches when each rocket is carrying
more than 7,000 kilograms of garbage.
That 3% failure rate isn't so reassuring anymore.
Is it a few freak accidents a year could have a devastating impact on our
atmosphere.
Our oceans and our soil,
not to mention the fatalities and damages that we'd occur when burning plastics
and heavy metal or raining from the sky.
And what if a failed rocket was carrying nuclear waste in this space?
What if accidents and emissions from the space waste program made our world
uninhabitable?
Would we be beyond saving?
In 1978 NASA scientists,
Donald Jay Kessler,
theorize that the accumulation of space debris over time could become so dense
that we could no longer use satellites or for that matter,
leave Earth's orbit.
We would be trapped in a toxic world surrounded by our own garbage,
and we would decay as well.
We don't like to think about where our garbage goes.
We're just glad to see it disappear,
but of course we can't really make it disappear and we can't just shoot it into
space and hope it floats away because what if it comes back?
What would that look like?
Hmm,
that's a question for another.
What if.